- Hey, everyone! What's up?
This is Luka Negoita.
I'm a data scientist and ecologist,
and I'm super stoked to
be launching my new course
on data visualization in R for ecologists.
(bright upbeat music)
So, this is the course that I wish I had
as a grad student in ecology.
If you're an ecologist or a biologist
and want to quickly
learn the essential tools
for making good figures,
this course is for you.
I tried to summarize everything
together in this nice,
concise three-hour short course
that goes over all the basics
of plotting data
efficiently and effectively,
trying to reduce the R learning
curve as much as possible,
just to the essential tools that you need
to really create professional
and publication-ready figures in R.
Through project-based
lessons and exercises,
I really just take you by the hand
beginning with the most basics
such as how to plot figures
using R's base package,
but then moving on to more
advanced topics such as ggplot2,
what it actually is, how it works,
and beginning to create
plots using ggplot2.
Specifically focusing on
five of the most essential
and common figures that
you find in ecology,
and how to plot them,
how to customize them,
how to annotate them.
Along the way, of course,
we're also gonna cover how to
save and export your figures,
and then also some of the best practices
for creating publication-quality figures.
Though this is an introductory
course to data visualization,
I do assume that you're
gonna be coming into it
with just a little bit of a background
in R and R Studio.
At least the basics,
knowing how to do some very
basic things with your data
will be important so that I don't...
because I'm not gonna
really spend a lot of time
on those topics in this course so...
and it's just gonna go right
into data visualization.
If you don't really have that background,
if you're still starting from scratch
and don't really know what to do,
then definitely check out my other course
on the basics of R for ecologists,
which offers a complete foundation
and all the basics that you need to know
for working with data in R.
And so, if you want to learn
more about that course,
there's a link down below
or actually maybe it's up above.
I'm not really sure where on
this website the links will be,
but somewhere on this website
where you're watching this video,
there will be links for signing up
for the basics of R for ecologists,
as well as this new course
on the intro to data visualization
with R for ecologists.
Thank you so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed.
Please share this with all your friends,
with your university,
with your department,
whoever you think might
enjoy these courses
or benefit from them.
So, until then.
Thanks again.
And I'll see you there.
(bright upbeat music continues)